>>Most of us grew up, classic
American education, you know.
You can go through a unit where
these was math, social studies
or English, and at the end
of the unit, you had a test.
Then you moved onto the next
unit, because you had to get
through all the chapters by
the end of the school year.
And some kids would do
well, some wouldn't.
Some kids got good
grades and some didn't.
>>In the past, we would just
move on to the next chapter
in the book, and sorry
if you didn't get that.
Maybe at the end
of the year review,
we'll try and touch on that.
We wanted to get away
from that practice.
We made sure that we
had a time in the day
where if students did
not master the skill
that was previously taught, we
gave them time to master that.
>>So these formatives are a
way of assessing everything
that you have learned about
prime and composite numbers.
>>So we're gonna go ahead
and get up our math offices.
Put your first, last
name on this test.
>>Nancy: Is this a test that
you have to take really fast?
>>Everybody: No.
>>Katie: What we do is
we teach an objective,
and that objective is
calendared out for us.
And at the end of
teaching that objective,
we would give a formative
assessment,
which is usually on Friday.
Objectives usually
last about a week.
And based on the results of
that formative assessment,
we know if students have
mastered that concept
or if they have not
mastered that.
Then what teachers do is, they
get together as a grade level
and they look at their
formatives, and they look
at what students mastered that
formative and which didn't,
and they divide students
into the reteach group
and into the enrich group.
>>Nancy: And so how many
reteaches are you looking at?
>>Lindsey: I'm looking
at five I reteach, yep.
>>Nancy: Crystal, do you
have your number yet?
>Crystal: Yes, nine.
>>Matt, what were your numbers?
>Matt: Eight.
>>Katie: One of the things that
we found through our experience
with reteach and enrich
is that the teacher
who had a very good turnout
on that formative assessment,
they did something
right in that classroom.
They did something right
with their instruction
on that objective.
>>Lindsey: Is it safe to say
a composite number is a number
that has more than two factors?
[Everybody:] Yes.
>>Lindsey: Very good.
All right, that's what
we're gonna write down.
>>Katie: So we felt that that
teacher would be the most
appropriate person to
teach the reteach group.
>>Nancy: I think they just
need a little more time
on this is what it looks like.
>>Lindsey: Exactly.
Well, I'm open to doing
reteach for prime and composite.
>>Nancy: What about what
you've got planned, Matt?
You had some enrichments
planned, didn't you?
>>Matt: Yeah, I did, I put
three enrich programs together
and three activities.
I took what you had and
I took what you had,
and I took a sample
on Marilyn Burns,
and I just kinda read all
three of them and I redid them
on my board, on one
of the poster boards.
And I wrote it in like a child
friendly version of it...
[Cheryl:] Of the
divisibility rules?
>>Yeah. And I gave an
example underneath each one.
>>Nancy: All right,
so are we all set?
Everybody feel comfy?
>>Lindsey: Sounds good to me.
>Cheryl: Yeah, I think so.
>>Katie: That following
week, every day,
Monday through Friday, from
twelve thirty to one o'clock,
we have reteach and enrich
going on school wide.
So the teachers that
are teaching reteach,
they have that reteach group
and they stay with that group
of students for that
entire week.
The enrichment students, they're
split up and they would rotate
between all of the other
teachers in that grade level.
>>Lindsey: Today in reteach,
we're going to be going
over prime and composite
numbers.
>>I think reteach
is kind of nice
because if you don't understand
something, you won't go
on until you understand it,
so you won't be confused
with anything else, and
the teachers do help you.
I realize that it's
not really bad.
It's just that you just need a
little bit more help with it.
>>Matt: You guys did really
well on your formative last week
and so today's your chance
to do an enrichment portion.
I really wanna challenge you.
I'm giving you that option.
Do you wanna do prime and
composite, zero to a hundred,
or do you wanna try
prime and composite,
zero to two hundred,
using those digits?
With a thumbs up, how many
of you guys wanna do a
hundred to two hundred?
All right.
I'm gonna go for the two hundred
too and I'll help you out
and I'll help you out as well.
>>Katie: We knew that it
worked because the very year
that we took our AIMs or
our standardized test,
our school became
an excelling school.
Our achievement is the highest
in the state of Arizona,
so that's something that
we're very proud of.
>>When we hold students
accountable
for very specific standards, and
we expect all of them to know
that standard, then we
hold ourselves accountable
for getting that job done.
And that is a very significant
shift from simply saying,
'You know what, I made it all
the way through the textbook.'